I realize
we're all a salad-spinner
of emotions right now, you know.
And, yeah, and feel
what you've got to feel.
You know, feel what
you got to feel.
But the way I see it,
now is not the time
to abandon America, you guys.
You don't want to go off and cry
in some hockey player's mullet.
You got to stay here.
-The most...
-(applause and cheering)
And I love Canada, but the most
American thing you can do
is stay here, be the best you
you can be,
make your community better.
Work, love your family,
be good to people.
(applause and cheering)
Because I want
to tell you something.
I want to tell you something,
now that I'm having
my (bleep) Oprah moment.
Now I want
to tell you something.
At the end of the day,
it is people,
it is each and every one
of you,
it is you watching
that make a country great.
Not some clown
sitting in the White House
-who thinks they can...
-(cheers and applause)
Like, we are too...
We put too much power
on that person,
whoever that person was gonna
be, to make our lives better.
We have to make our (bleep)
lives better, so don't...
-(applause and cheering)
-You guys make America great.
You (bleep) make America great.